this video is part of project homecoming
but more on that later
the strongarian empire as its name
suggests was divided into two parts the
austrian
and the hungarian these parts were then
further subdivided on the austrian side
today's czechia was divided into bohemia
moravia and silesia and on the hungarian
side today slovakia was
just hungary hungary was very particular
in its idea of
who cares it's all mine then again
that's the idea followed by any imperial
nation not just hungary but
i digress this direct control of
slovakia by hungary for about a thousand
years but more prominent than the last
200
meant that slovaks even though having a
very small number of intellectuals which
ended up leading the nationalistic
movement in the 19th and early 20th
century
had practically speaking no middle or
higher class
most slovaks were farmers miners and
low-skilled factory workers
when we compare that to the chicks it's
a very different picture
bohemia was a very prominent kingdom
within the hre and even though it then
fell under the habsburg control it
always retained a certain kind of
autonomy
meaning the czech people had a thriving
middle class an aristocracy and numerous
intellectuals
this is not to mean they weren't
restrained at all by austrian rules and
in fact almost any middle
or high class check had to know german
if they wanted to progress their career
in
any meaningful way but when compared to
the solvax they were leaps ahead in
social progress
and personal freedoms with all that said
by the end of the 19th century
both czechs and slovaks were fighting
for some sort of autonomy
whether that be recognized equality
within the empire or complete secession
from it
depends on who you ask there were many
movements each with a differing goal and
a different plan to get there
in czechia the most prominent political
views by the end of the 19th century
didn't really consider slovakia this is
not to say there weren't any czech
movements for the formation of
czechoslovakia or at the very least
support for the slovak brothers in one
way or another but none of these
movements by the end of the 19th century
were prevalent in the czech mindset
being vastly overshadowed by the czech
fear of germanification which spurred up
the czech nationalistic movement
campaign for equal rights and
self-autonomy
because if czechs had the means to
administer their own lands they would no
longer have to fear and could even
counteract
germanification but even though this
idea was almost universal amongst all
czech political parties they disagreed
on how to tackle it
nonetheless by far the most prominent
movement was best described by
karaoke a czech politician the lands of
the bohemian crown
formed an undividable and indivisible
whole
completely independent and autonomous
vis-a-vis the other lands of their king
hence advocating for remaining within
the empire while gaining the autonomy
like hungary had
and in fact by the end of the 19th
century many czechs didn't want to
secede from the empire they just wanted
more autonomy switching from the czechs
to slovaks now the most prominent and in
fact the only faction to see some
success in slovak circles was the
nationalistic party
by the late 19th and early 20th century
it had a newspaper based from martin
called naruto nyanovini which was edited
by vyansky
this party as its name suggests was very
much nationalistic with some members
boarding on what we would today call
fascism
its agenda early on centered around the
full secession from the empire and the
creation
of independent slovakia on top of that
the party was known for its russophilia
anti-westernism anti-semitism and
agrarianism
after seeing no political success and
very strong suppression by the
hungarians
the nationalistic party became less
radical going into the 20th century
abandoning the idea of full succession
of slovakia and campaigning for
universal suffrage and equal rights for
slovaks within the empire
however anti-westernism anti-semitism
and rusophilia
still remain strong with the more
right-leaning members of the party
also the idea of a czechoslovakian state
was very much a moot point within the
nationalistic circles
not gaining any traction and it is this
political state that disgruntled young
slovaks found themselves around the turn
of the century
with the only prominent political party
being very conservative and the czechs
pretty much
mining their own business giving the
slovaks a thumbs up of encouragement
across the morava
but this is all just one side of the
story and it is time to turn to the
other side
which largely revolves around one man
known today as
tatic masarik
tomas masarik was born in a small town
of hodojin right on the border between
czechia and slovakia
when he was six his family moved to a
neighboring town of chekovitsa
his father was a sobak farmer and his
mother at germanized moravian
masari grew up speaking as aharat's
dialect of slovak but at an early age
also learned german and czech from his
mother he wasn't particularly fond of
manual labor
preferring academia of all for example
as a teenager he taught himself latin
and ancient greek just so he could read
the original classical texts
he was also at the top of his class at a
gymnasium in brno and later vienna
while there he also learned french
russian polish and english
and earned a bit of money by translating
documents from those languages to german
or czech
interestingly while he was at gymnasium
when he turned 17
he joined the number of young hotheads
who sallied forth to fight for their
country in the austro-russian war also
known in germany as the unification war
he got injured during the war and
recovered in bratislava before finishing
up his gymnasium
after which he continued pursuing his
passion for academia enrolling at the
university of vienna from which he got
his eventual doctorate in 1876.
during this entire time masarik wasn't
involved much in politics and even
though he himself admitted to be a
sympathizer for czech and slovak
autonomy
outside of joining a few small slovakian
czech student unions in vienna
he never actively did anything instead
he was fully immersed in his studies of
philosophy
history psychology etc but that all
changed in 1881-2 when he got a post as
a philosophy professor at charles
university
it was in prague that he was very much
thrown onto the czech political stage
through the academic connections he made
there all of whom were already involved
in politics
his early political life and ascendance
is quite complicated but the main event
that can be pointed to
is the hilsner case the hilsner case was
a series of trials against the jewish
peddler
for committing a ritual murder of a
young czech girl
the evidence against him was laughable
and only situated on the
unlikability of his character and the
fact that he was jewish
however most of the czech politics at
the time involved anti-semitism
and much of the public wanted to see
someone face some repercussions
masarik however even though stating he
wasn't very fond of hilsner decided to
seemingly go against almost all
politicians and the public opinion
because in his eyes this monstrous
non-legality
could not stand in a just nation with
massari's help hilsner was still
convicted but instead of being executed
he was given life imprisonment
during this nationwide incident masarik
was shown to the entire population
as an honor as man and a fighter for
justice his idea of an
unpleasant truth is preferable to a
beneficial eye became one of his core
political beliefs and he went on to find
a new political check party called the
realists
in 1900 this party was meant to replace
the current
young czech party that masari viewed as
pandering to the empire just as well as
to the czech people
resulting in nothing being done the
realist party was very liberal for its
time equating for full equality of women
in the workplace
universal suffrage freedom of speech etc
also unlike the czech parties up until
now it actively worked with other slavic
parties in austria-hungary including
croats serbs
slovaks etc at the same time masarikoso
helped coordinate a small number of
slovak intellectuals studying in czechia
to find a new political movement against
the conservative slovak nationalists
these people founded the newspaper class
that focused around social democratic
ideas and became a prominent counter to
the nationalistic party
as the great war was drawing nigh almost
none of the major czech or slovak
politicians
including masarik propagated at least
officially any idea of succession from
the empire
instead they all supported the proposed
federalist state of
austria-hungary which was also supported
by archduke franz ferdinand
it also has to be noted that outside of
a small minority like the group
czechoslovakia nota
the idea of a czechoslovak state was
never proposed on any major political
level
even masarik though his actions and
rhetoric in the early 19th century
were very much so heading towards a
unified czechoslovakia
never actually publicly stated he wanted
a czechoslovak union
until 1907. most scholars today believe
it was his plan all along to unify the
czechs and the slovaks a people who he
called
co-nationals he just wanted to stir up
more political support for such a move
before declaring it officially
and reading his lecture notes i think
this becomes very clear
nonetheless whatever political agenda
and views both sides had
when it became clear that the great war
was inevitable the czechs and slovaks
started to view a mutual cooperation
as the best chance towards an
independent and strong country
and just like that masarik who was
working towards a unified czechoslovak
state for decades now
became the center point of the
czechoslovak independence movement
during the war
at the start of the war masarik viewed
the german and austrian mobilization and
he had this to say
i could not help feeling impressed by
the purposeful german discipline
and the preparedness to the last button
throughout the mobilization i did not
see
a single drunken german whereas the
contingents of the austrian recruits on
their way home to join the war
were for the most part helplessly
intoxicated
no real point for this quote i just
thought it was funny
however two quotes do summarize
masarik's life for the next four years
quite well
singer and men who met masarik at the
beginning of the war
said this the impression which maserik
produced on me was
extraordinary he was entirely taken up
with one single idea
this man who was an austrian against his
will
was engrossed by the question whether
the historical moment had come
when the empire was to be split up into
its national ingredients
during this time masarik also met with
professor seton watson
with whom he created the memorandum for
central europe
watson later said this about that the
program
which masarik placed before me at that
secret meeting in a hotel rotterdam in
october 1914
was fulfilled almost to the letter in
october 1918.
so masari had a plan and he had the will
to execute
it therefore the next four years masarik
took the initiative
almost single-handedly getting
diplomatic support for the creation of
czechoslovakia across the world
he traveled to rotterdam geneva paris
london petrograd moscow kiev vladivostok
tokyo chicago washington new york
london paris and in 1918 prague
masarik was the one to organize the
czechoslovak legion in russia and later
he was the one to
negotiate safe passage of this legion
across russia he also had time to be one
of the founders of the ucl school of
slavonic and east european studies
in london and many other things we don't
have time to talk about
however it wasn't all smooth sailing for
gaining diplomatic support for the
creation of czechoslovakia
the most prominent opposition coming
from the british who didn't want to
break up the austro-hungarian empire
especially not at the start of the war
america on the other hand proved to be
the most enthusiastic ally of maserik
and his cause
when he arrived to chicago he was
joyfully greeted by a hundred and
fifty thousand people most of which were
of czechoslovakia origin
eventually thanks to masarik and
relentless diplomatic work
and new nation was founded a
czechoslovak nation
a nation comprised of two brothers and a
nation that massarix stressed
should always remain unified for only in
unity can the small czech and slovak
nations
retain importance on a larger political
stage
unsurprisingly masarik was elected as
the first president of czechoslovakia
and a new chapter not just in masarik's
life but also in czechoslovak history
began
a chapter that until 1938
had a lot of its own problems but that's
a story for another time
this video is part of a greater project
homecoming where for the holidays a
bunch of history youtubers are talking
about the history of where they
live or where they are from since i'm
from slovakia i talked about the
formation of czechoslovakia if you want
to see the other history youtubers
videos
click the link to the playlist on the
screen or in the description
my name is mlazer and see you next time